bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono oggi molto
orgoglioso di presentarvi un gioco in
anteprima un gioco che non è stato fatto
da una persona a caso ma una persona che
nella mia vita anche abbastanza
importante perché è stata uno dei primi
youtubers che ho iniziato seguì italiani
che ho iniziato a seguire sulla
piattaforma youtube ica e si tratta di
daniele doesn't matter
daniele mi scrive mesetto due mesetti
farmi ricordo dicendo che ha sviluppato
un videogioco horror
daniele ma melo servi così su un piatto
d'argento allora proviamo il videogioco
horror di daniele dai suoi matter
doesn't matter games sarà un continuo di
violenza sangue temi sensibili allora se
non vuoi che io sia eminem farli dorare
un po di più i testi premiati indossare
cuffie si abbiamo la prelibata 63 10 ai
nuova partita benvenuto lo saranno in
viaggio attraverso la psiche di george
siam partiti che siamo dentro un regia
daniele servite a c'è anche proprio tipo
tipo film ma che bravo no way una musica
italiana in un horror mi fa stranissimo
costruzione da linee selvitella
faccio anche il bit award
ma dove l'hai trovata daniele una foto
di me sveglio al mattino lost alon
sorellina che è un nome molto strano
italiano inglese con sorellina un little
sister
george lepre si cura di laura alla
sorella della sua fidanzata anna laura è
molto malata dalle le sue medicine o
siamo partiti eccoci qua luce quando in
una stanza decorata iacente dal blues e
beh effettivamente
c'è un'ombra a daniele ma sei matto ma
come cazzo hai fatto
ha fatto benissimo a non me lo
immaginavo mai va bene è
casa mia ciao giorgio ci lascio ti
lascio questo punto perché dato che
l'attuale maria è pessima questa mattina
secondo tuscia molto presto per per quel
colloquio tieni le dita incrociate per
me sa rodia tutto il weekend prenditi
cura di mia sorella laura mia a [ __ ]
a soreta cosa ti metti o
possiamo rovinare un'amicizia stai calmo
a ho aperto la il cassetto così adesso
la chiave è chiaro che
cabina armadio e capitola su cielo la
chiave adesso ce l'ho allora la chiave
del corridoio ok
vai in cucina e prendi l'acqua per laura
laura se posso farti una domanda ma così
vi sorge spontanea che cazzo di problemi
ai nell'arredamento chiamo avanti
ragazzi ciucci di gigi d'alessio metti a
posto i dischi di papà 0 su 6 giu ma che
cazzo però
altro incredibile ci cascano sulla casa
i fulmini per depositare la gente le
corse l'esenzione l'oggetto di calci
sono pratica nuovamente per aprire il
menu contestuale
a te che cazzo mi serve è comunque la
bambina ancora non si è visto alla
sinistra alla destra bellis i quadri ha
proprio preso il quadro picchia tutto
laura cioè torcicollo
c'è una puzza terribile e ho capito ma
non credo che sia questo il problema
penso che sia il più il problema di una
che dietro ci
va bene queste belle buoni daniels e
cucini così non ci venga a mangiare a
casa tua che compiono cucina diverso
adesso che c'è una bottiglia posso
andare in camera da letto
sono michele 23 sole 20 a costa possa
ancora che cazzo è un topo gigio pinkas
che l'italiano è questa assurda sta cosa
ma queste daniele ma cosa ce l'ha fatta
lui e il fratello di anna non andiamo a
volta d'accordo a un obiettivo
completato è fino a qua
grazie grazie ragazzi ora non so da li
metti di 23 fulmini versione che proprio
mi sento di voler morire giovane grazie
mille
vado che ho messo il bicchiere e grafici
cook tu stai in bagno ho
già chi ci sei ma vai comunicate a post
it tipo francesco sole non so già che ci
sei mi mi porti anche una fetta di pizza
laura
è una fetta di cura nella porta la fetta
di pizza non si sente
cosa cazzo era non ho mica letto ho
detto io poi l'ho letto effettivamente
manca la corrente giu 62 pure che c'è
una freccia qua attiva la corrente poi
c'e la freccia
contatore
george ennesima lettera visto in questi
giorni salta spesso l'apparente se
questa sera come di sera dove siamo
andati alla luce ti scrivo il codice per
la stanza del contatore 11538 ma cosa
faccio prendo prima la pinza vado prima
raccontato rabbia prima ora pizza
intanto
11 53 ore kabul
poi appena cioè
a una chiave in mano ma non la lascia
forse possono sostituirlo con altro
con cosa sostituire una tua foto veli
dopo la morte di vincita di questa roba
è diventata mio migliore amico pensate
ammetto che è un esserino un po
pretenzioso non si ottiene nulla per
nulla ricordatelo tutti voglio qualcosa
anche le bambole silenzi e generosa
george laura ma io devo è una
psicopatica la zia faccio del libero
faccio quello che mette all'elettricista
tutto tutto
e poi le salette daniele che parla con
la voce bambina voglio risentirla fabio
bellissima da lì bravo mi è piaciuta
questa
11538 ve ne ho sbagliato ecco
11538 saltata la corrente un caz
devo fare io tanto ma guardate qua ci
state così della scacchiera che
effettivamente non raccolti già un sacco
di posso mettere daniele doesn't matter
altri libri daniel
ok la zia
c'è la muffa sul muro ragazzi fate
cagare cioè nel senso pulite qual è la
bocca del pesce può ospitare un oggetto
daniel george l'edificio che chiesto la
pizza e si è sparito ti aspetti in
camera non mi sento bene credo che mi
mettono a letto non svegliarmi laura
fatto tutto lei fa tutto lei tutto era
data ad accendere la
la luce è stata
la zia la zia che è vera c'è qualcosa
che non mi torna c'è una nuda anna
capitana
chiara perché è
bellissimo cioè la fatti bene brother tu
ne sai e
cioè fai anche il tentatore per poi
avere jobs mammamia daniele manca la
corea può ancora porco demonio tirata su
prima
boh aiko la lanterna bellina way per
accenderla 1
accusiamo così accesa posso aprire
eccoci io andrei di sopra detto libro
qua io andrei proprio di sopra in
soffitta visto che ciò che diceva solo
quando c'è la luce lanterna poi salterà
premendo uno da vantarsi scarica per
ricaricare la terapia pajala noi davvero
nella terna ok e metti che non erano
daniele fiammiferi
un altro contatore è bello chiusa
elettronica qui io devo mettere i
fusibili e non ho trovato uno che cazz
costi fulmini che troveremo fusibili
cerchiamo i fusibili
salve e quasi vede bello
ritratto del padre di anna laura e jenny
era un marinaio
a quest'anno e cosi che ho trovato in
giro va bene adesso c'è poi borsone
ok vediamo se riesco a trovare quel coro
fusibile ce l'abbiamo la campana forse
lo mettere quella campana blocco
catenaccio tutti così mani da marinaio
corretto ancora inoltre per adesso mi
metto tre
tac tac
tac che ne mancano due una con uno qua
hanno questo qua eh già è già lì ok
mancano due pezzi
cassetta attrezzi da pesca
una bella chiave dello studio ci hanno
comunicato quanto nelle note avrà ha
mandato avanti di industria dei quei due
sul server per questo serve se non
sbaglio sono gli zii di laura
ma che social eccetto daniele anche io
voglio re del sé sinergo come zii
però credo che lo siano loro servizi c'è
sicuramente di voi lo sanno bene come
fossi un nipote
ma lasciamoli pure essere gli zii di di
di laura che è meglio posso tornare lì
soprano sono arrivato
giovanna è a posto io vado a fare anzi
guarda prendono che mi manca il fusibile
sta offrendo fusibile poi torno sarò
peperonata scendo cazzate attesi da
questa poi è a
che cazzo trovato chi galleggiante da
pesca va bene
un calice stein faccio di galleggianti
la pesca un picco qua
qua
galleggiante da peano galleggiante la
pesca e
sembra che manchi qualcosa dotti carico
maronna ruga arm
vabbè ho capito semplicemente devo
andare a ficcarlo nella bocca del pesce
perché alla fine è così che si pescano
teoricamente credo è non ne sono
sicurissimo sono esperte di pesca
proprio meno ecco qua ma che cazzo
staccato a test chiave 101
a cassetto 101 eccola qua cabina armadio
chiave camera dei genitori
questa mi mancava fratte a lei cellula
chiave camerali genitori buongiorno
che bella voglia di vero bene di di
scoprire che ebbe comunque tutto uguale
c'è qua i quadri lavato la bambina con
il mal di pancia
ma perché daniele
perché
e giacomo hai fatto uscire il cane
un'altra volta ma non è normale questo
salve giorno c'era nelle parti questa
stanza è come gaza è arrivato che non è
tanto strano che c è come è arrivato
dentro però vabbè giorno cadaveri di
papa
abbiamo fatto un cazzo
ma come la porta è bloccata cacchio
manca la corretta
salve
facci docas
le domeniche d'agosto vantava neve di
qua
chi cazzo è questa laura sei tu no anna
daniele
cadavere di anna
oddio benedetto che
ha posto pulito va bene
grande
questo lo prendo grazie felicina
medicine giorgio ti ricordi cosa devi
fare e dalla banalità vince la varia le
23 tele sta dimenticando vero sono le
comperino sotto questa lettera non puoi
sbagliare
ti amo anna
bloccata alla volta meccanismo si
passeggia in una casa piena di
meccanismi non è che sono sherlock è già
uscito con 60 al diploma andalo sai e
quadro è sì certo che questo però perché
non me lo fa esaminare e chiudono
all'oggetto 932 sicuro perché c'è anche
lo stesso quadro e 932 al mille per
cento col nome lo fa esaminare perché
forse perché c'è questo
no è un bug
sarà un bug
no magari un bug prova riavviare perché
questa stanza qui vediamo un attimo se
credo sia un bug perché sul codice
quindi
[Musica]
ma
ma dove sabato la partita
ma come
[Musica]